hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday July 29th 2019 what's going on
how are ya how's it going oh oh am I in
a good mood I am in a great mood why
because I haven't watched the Red Sox
all year long I've sort of been seeing
what's going on I've I checked the
standings I've watched maybe one game
maybe two games but now that they've won
three in a row I don't know what
happened last night because I'm
recording this on Sunday before it
happened I don't know what happened but
now that they've won three in a row I'm
gonna do what every fan and Buffalo Wild
Wings would do is I'm gonna pretend like
I've been watching them all year oh yeah
you like that I will take this as far as
like what I was paying attention to I
remember it was a game about three weeks
ago this incredible game that the
Yankees played where it was just a back
and forth thing and they were down a
bunch of runs and they ended up winning
like 16 to 14 or something like that and
one of my buddies was like that's one of
the greatest baseball games I ever saw
in the back of my head I'm like the
number that excites me there would be
the 14 14 runs you're [ __ ] let up you
know I forgot who they were playing but
I mean I mean I've been I tell you right
now I'm gonna Pat myself on my freckled
[ __ ] back I've been preaching this
forever regular season stats are so
[ __ ] overrated all right you
shouldn't say that you should just
really pay attention to what you're
looking at what you're getting excited
about because you know 80% of the league
is not gonna be there come playoff time
so I think they should I don't know why
they don't do this what they should have
like overall team stats and then stats
against the top whatever whatever
percentage of the league makes the
playoffs so in baseball whatever it is
the top 12% you know basketball and
hockey the top 90% you could just use
regular season stats
any [ __ ] everybody makes it look like
sixteen teams at both conferences make
it if it seems like eight teams so it is
sixteen and hockey I don't know I don't
even want it isn't basketball like half
the [ __ ] league so but I think with
like football and baseball regular
season stats if you just look at them
without taking into context who can you
please shut the [ __ ] door good God
Almighty every time she walks out she
leaves the door open my kid is sleeping
wait she's coming back in I'm gonna read
her the riot act near Ania Hill hi Bill
burr from TMZ we want to know why you
have a difficult time closing the door
when you go to walk in and out no
comment
what do you think about some of this to
sweat shop labor in El Salvador are you
doing anything about it to try and you
know alleviate some of the stresses from
what we hear there's there's children as
young as nine making Victoria's Secret
thongs oh I stopped banks eight years
ago why is that was it because that was
did you feel like a basic [ __ ] yeah
exactly where exactly where exactly do
you for our podcast listeners just one
more question just one more question for
our podcast listeners where isn't that
you let you prefer to buy your
undergarments are you saying that you go
natural yes a commando ok
ok can you give us a shout-out be like
hey this is nearing a hill and you're
listening to the Monday morning podcast
hey this is MIA Renee Hill and you're
anyway so I went down today always
saying always talking about the [ __ ]
stats who gives a [ __ ] so this is if
you're a real sports fan cuz right now
of course you know I bought a New York
Post today because I loved watching the
New York sports writers they flip out
you know the Yankees or whatever
football team I guess every sports team
by a Boston sports wears do it too
whatever's happening is what's gonna
happen if your team won five games in a
row they ever
again so now the Yankees are they having
a [ __ ] weekend obviously happens to
everybody no matter how good you are now
they're flipping out something we shall
see I like how they're like there
they're 11 game lead has now been
whittled down to eight it's like yeah
it's pretty comfortable even if we get
it down to seven the way they've been
playing this year they're bats and
everything I don't think that they're in
any danger a long way to go so I don't
know if this always happens at some
point during the year you're gonna head
a little bit of a slump all right but
you have to understand these are
professional athletes and what the
Yankees you're dealing with the
professional athletes that play in the
New York City you know media market
whatever the [ __ ] so it's just non-stop
pressure so they're gonna be I think
they're gonna be fine as excited as I am
if we do actually sweep them that's
always fun but we're still gonna be
seven [ __ ] games out and you know
even up in Boston they're like only
we're gonna turn a key here well you
know you know it's like you don't sports
writers are like sports our days are
like [ __ ] you know they're like you
know that [ __ ] you know never goes to
the gym and then goes to the gym like
one or two days in a row and just dude
I'm crushing it I'm talking right now
I'm gonna get [ __ ] apps all right mark
my words get my [ __ ] ABS you know
three days later you catch them in a
[ __ ] you know dipping a Fudgsicle
into a cake you know so anyway but I
this is I'm just glad the Red Sox are
finally being competitive with the
Yankees because the Yankees been like a
[ __ ] steamroll of a whole year and
you know [ __ ] what's better than
[ __ ] late September October baseball
it's the [ __ ] best I love well I'm
sure there's a lot of things better you
know but I like it I like it that we're
gonna be in it you know God does we
spend enough money every year we learned
it from the Yankees and we're not gonna
stop doing it we've now bought a [ __ ]
soccer team over there and the
Premiership we're siphoning the money
off from that you don't had a chance to
go to that Liverpool game up at Yankee
Stadium my [ __ ] guy you know of course
my shooting schedule didn't work out
yes I did just say that my shooting
schedule and I'm wearing sunglasses we
shot I don't want to say where we shop a
went on it's been all over Atlanta and
we've been having a good time and I
don't we're getting down to it here and
what's weird when it's during the
working week I have no anxiety
whatsoever on the weekends when we're
off I have anxiety I don't know what it
is
this scene how am I gonna do that scene
how many boys are there freaking the
[ __ ] out of his mustache keeps getting
in my food but if I'm just working that
I'd then it's fine I don't know what it
is it's weird so I go downstairs today
once I didn't even know though I knew
the Red Sox and Yankees were playing
each other but I had no idea that we had
won three games in a row man that we
were kicking the [ __ ] out of might know
it that's how out of the [ __ ] loop I
am so I hate my parents are in town one
of them mentioned it so like oh [ __ ]
it's one of my favorite things to do
when the Red Sox are winning finally I
like reading New York sports pages
because I like watching them [ __ ] act
like the sky is falling so I go down to
buy the paper all right and you know to
have a little [ __ ] enjoyment and in
the front page of the paper is one of
those stories that is so [ __ ] sad but
it happened to an individual and nobody
did it to him he did it to himself so
it's like why do I need to know this
doesn't the person feel bad enough now I
know that that happened if you guys
don't want any I'm gonna say the story
really quickly if you don't want to hear
it just fast-forward through this or
I'll give you a second I'm gonna tell
the story a dream yeah one some guy he
had twins two beautiful babies all right
and he left him in the car it heated up
when they both died and then he was
allegedly screaming I killed my babies
okay he feels horrible it's manslaughter
they're charging with all this [ __ ] why
the [ __ ] do i nee what does it do for me
to know that story the guy feels [ __ ]
horrible you're publishing his [ __ ]
name
I'm
he's probably on suicide watch why the
[ __ ] do I need to know that I went out
there like oh boy that the team that the
[ __ ] hits the ball with this stick
that represents my city did real well
for three games I want to read about it
and I literally walked up the street
just going oh my god oh yeah I get like
mad at the paper I could see if somebody
came in and did that to his kids we got
to find that guy here's the suspect
that's bad enough but that there's a
reason why I should know that Daryl made
me want to like give the [ __ ] paper
back get my money back I don't know why
they published [ __ ] you know it's a
great front-page story oh so now I did
it to you right but you know why you
know why I think that happened no I
didn't do anything I went to a play last
night
oh Jesus bill we'd lost you now you're
eight months sober you're reading Ken
Stabler's autobiography not exactly
reading it is reading but it's not too
in-depth you're growing mustaches for a
[ __ ] fan now you're going to a
[ __ ] play what happened to your
freckles I don't know what happened I
think I became a big phony so my parents
went out I took him to go see the To
Kill a Mockingbird my buddy actually got
the tickets it was hilarious he got the
tickets and I thought he bought him for
us cuz I thought he knew the star of the
play and he was hooking us up so I'm
going to my parents hey be sure you say
thanks for the tickets so they said hey
thanks for the tickets and I should have
known when he [ __ ] in his text
message he had the price of the tickets
I was sitting there going I was kind of
tacky I get it you know you're doing us
a favor
why I didn't need to know the exact
numerical amount so I went in that was
like hey dude I go thanks again for the
tickets
and I saw that look on his face and I
[ __ ] knew and I just started laughs I
said oh [ __ ] was I supposed to give you
some money and then he was able to joke
his way out of it and and he goes not
[ __ ] up whatever he goes out by ammo by
him I go no no no no and I brought my
parents that's three [ __ ] tickets you
want to pay for tickets and it was like
as much as I would like to stick you for
all this money
Jesse could bring it up for the rest of
your life so I ended up paying so any we
sought to kill a mockingbird starring
Jeff Daniels he highly underrated Jeff
Daniels you know people just think he
does comedy because I think the first
time mainstream people learned about him
was Dumb and Dumber absolutely crushed a
roll it was [ __ ] amazing if you're in
New York you get a chance to see it one
of the most incredible things about it
was how many actors there were and how
they had to like move the sets on and
off stage themselves and there would be
all of this movement going on but the
way they lit it and the way people came
out you are always looking at the person
you were supposed to be looking at and
then all of a sudden you'd be like oh
[ __ ] when did when did the star of the
play get out that even see him come out
this it's incredible so anyway we're at
the play and sitting there and joined
it's like 2 hours and 40 minutes long
which I was like oh [ __ ] man this has
got to be brutal and it wasn't it flew
by it [ __ ] flew by obviously it's an
intense story so in the dialogue you
know no wasted words so you're in it
just in case you're not a fan of the
theatre this is something you should
definitely check out so what watch you
want having a good time now shoot are
you familiar with the movie to kill a
mockingbird you know came out a long
time ago Robert Duvall a young Robert
Duvall was in it
spoiler alert I don't want to ruin this
but they all are in order to tell the
story I have to tell you what this
[ __ ] [ __ ] did a couple rows back
and he did it twice
alright now you have plenty of time I
don't tell a story for about two minutes
you have plenty of time to head stop all
right Mel maybe what if you getting on
an airplane right now and you're
struggling with your bags and you put it
in the overhead compartment I got it I
got a you know I got a wait a second do
you put your bag down huh you folded up
suits I for the life of me I don't get
how that that piece of luggage works you
know the the garment bag and you fold it
up and then you put the strap over and
somehow you take it out and your suit
should I just have one big drink
right across it one big one rather than
a bunch of little ones it shouldn't have
one big one evidently it works I don't
know if you bend it over at the waist
but the code hangs down half of it past
it I mean I don't know all right that
was enough [ __ ] eighties comedy
there to get me past that so was sitting
there watching the play all right and
there's one guy in the play who
everybody thinks is the town drunk so
what a pivotal part of the play he comes
walking out and you're like oh here's
the town drunk and he's got it he's got
in his bag a bottle of booze drinking
out of a paper bag and some kid on a you
know kid he's just a kid is
hyperventilating in the play and he goes
here have a sip and thinking oh my god
he's given him booze and when the kid
takes the sip he finds out that it's
coca-cola and the whole time the whole
town thought that he was a drunk he
wasn't he was actually stone sober I
don't know if he didn't like society or
whatever he was just there on it's a
long [ __ ] story so as he sips it as
he's giving it to the kid some [ __ ]
[ __ ] some [ __ ] [ __ ]
by like two rows behind me just goes
it's soda pop and there was no clue that
it was soda pop he clearly saw the movie
or had already seen the play and he was
like how [ __ ] insecure do you have to
be as a person to [ __ ] say that loud
enough that I'm to rose up and
diagonally away from this guy like five
[ __ ] people away that we all have to
heal like in his world we were all like
wow how did that guy figure that out is
he a gumshoe is he some sort of a sleuth
I have to turn around and see if he's
holding a big magnifying glass up to one
of his [ __ ] eyeballs ah oh my it took
everything in me the play was too good
and I respected the fact that everybody
else didn't he just it's soda pump and
then the kid just goes I know it's
coca-cola oh I wish I wish I had more
Patrice in me because I would have said
something but you know what no one else
heard it but I so just wanted to turn
around when he just goes it's soda pop
and
whoa coca-cola I don't want to just turn
around just be like [ __ ] and that has
been in my [ __ ] head for like I saw
it last night I can't stop thinking
about laughing in my apartment it's soda
pop soda pop how would you know it's
soda pop you've obviously seen it before
you obviously not want us to think that
you're [ __ ] smart and you and your so
you so need that you so need that that
you're gonna spoil this part of the
[ __ ] play you're gonna make that
about you
alright and then and then he did it
again he did it again the [ __ ]
[ __ ] did it again alright
spoiler alert coming again I'm letting
you guys know this is a podcast you can
[ __ ] fast-forward alright so there's
another part okay where there's a guy
who they also think is you know you know
deaf and dumb or whatever like there's a
mute or some [ __ ] there's like something
wrong with them right it's sort of the
theme of the play as far as people
looking at somebody and judging them by
how they look and getting it totally
[ __ ] wrong so the end of the [ __ ]
play the mute hasn't talked the entire
[ __ ] time and he's standing there
this girl asked him a question you're
expecting him not to talk and in that
moment you're gonna learn that this guy
is not a mute and can actually speak so
in that pregnant pause well you really
paid attention to the woman they're in
our anguish you know and then he's gonna
shock you by then talking that [ __ ]
[ __ ] two rows back five [ __ ]
people over it just goes say something
oh my god oh the douche chills and this
is what killed me I was the only person
who [ __ ] reacted I was the only one
who turned around trying to find the
douche everybody else just sat there and
then it made me feel like I'm I [ __ ]
here and things like am I such an angry
redheaded [ __ ] former redhead red
mustachioed [ __ ] alright with an
acceptable level of chest hair
am i that am i that [ __ ] bad that
[ __ ] angry a [ __ ] that that this
only bugs me you know I was with my
buddy he [ __ ] writes for a living
writes and directs and all that [ __ ] it
didn't bug him he didn't even hear it
and I'm [ __ ] hanging that [ __ ] how did
you not [ __ ] hear it anyway so I hope
that doesn't happen when you go to see
To Kill a Mockingbird cuz other than
that man it was [ __ ] amazing I should
really I should have had a shout out for
the other cast my members I think the
woman that I was talking about I believe
she wanted Tony always nominated or
something like that but uh it's kind of
been cool coming back in you know I saw
burn this with Adam driver and then I
saw To Kill a Mockingbird with Jeff
Daniels and when I lived here twelve
years ago I lived here for like ten
years right and I never went
I never went cuz I was too busy trying
to establish myself as a comedian and
last night I was listening to people
going oh I saw this play was so and so
and so and so and like like I heard Jeff
Daniels is gonna do this through what
you got to see him right he's doing this
through noon November and you know he's
coming in to replace him Edie [ __ ]
Harris and I was like Jesus criminy go
see this again
ed Harris is one of my favorite actors
of all time not to mention when I
started losing my hair he was one of the
guys I looked at I was like well ed
Harris is working you know jean-luc
Picard you know all my [ __ ] heroes
changed Telly Savalas
anyways I got to see him in that too so
I remember a long time ago the only
reason why I went and I saw this play
man I saw it what the [ __ ] was I forget
the other guy's name I don't know why
I'm blanking on him he was in Ricky
Bobby I'm just gonna push it down I'm
just gonna push it down why am i blanket
on his name I saw true West with uh with
Philip Seymour Hoffman and he's on he's
on that [ __ ] dude what is wrong with
my brain john c reilly speaking of ed
harris they were in state of grace which
was based on that book the Westies john
c reilly also an amazing musician i saw
him live at largo he's [ __ ]
incredible anyway I saw the two of them
do this play and they and they would
like switch like it was a two-person
play and every time every other play
they would they would every other
performance they would switch roles and
and that kind of [ __ ] was going on all
the time when I was here in New York and
God forbid I took a night off from
stand-up to go see these amazing [ __ ]
actors I don't you know I was just
always in the climene it worked for me
but I don't think you know I think when
I saw true West - I had a little anxiety
when I was sitting before the show
started I had this anxiety of like going
like I should have got a stand-up New
York tonight should I could have got a
spot in and maybe I can do a spot after
this and the woman I was dating or you
know I would have pissed her off so I
didn't about anyways I don't know I'm
just saying you should definitely check
that [ __ ] out and every time I come here
Bryan Cranston just wrapped up doing
something so I always missed that but
tonight I'm gonna go see that new
Tarantino movie speaking of which and I
can't believe this that this many years
went by I actually saw Pulp Fiction the
first time I saw was in Boston and then
the second time I saw it was in 94
and I believe I saw it would Dane Cook
we were a couple of kids just coming
down in New York I think Dane had come
down moved down here first and I was
getting my [ __ ] together to move down
here god that was such a great [ __ ]
time in my life I was scared
[ __ ] shitless and excited to move
down in New York but I came down I think
I was crashing with him and we had both
already seen it we wanted to see it
again so we saw it I think that that the
Lincoln Center AMC at Lincoln Center
the Lincoln whatever AMC the one on the
Upper West Side would still exist and I
was walking by there the other day and I
wasn't going to the Upper West Side
comedy club and and I was just thinking
I was just thinking of that Tarantino
somebody just told me that they had seen
it or they heard of crazy amazing review
because it's getting amazing reviews now
stake of Allen take my wife I'll go to
the same theater all those years later
so I think we're gonna go there tonight
but she wants to go to a different
theater which is probably a nicer
theater you know but I don't know I'm
kind of thinking nostalgic wise I'm
gonna go back there for that one I'll
check that out you can tell I'm looking
at a million things I'm waiting for my
[ __ ] podcast information to come in
here because right now is the time in
the podcast we're all freckles usually
[ __ ] sends a couple up reads a couple
of uh advertisers grabbing less emails
now we'll send over in ten minutes or so
well let's see if he set it over I feel
like I'm on a game show right now you
know live reads there they are oh boy
all right
feels uh hmm do you experience stress
yes yes I do it's soda pop oh my god
that [ __ ] or have anxiety or
chronic pain or have trouble sleeping at
least once a week you're not alone all
right wait I don't have chronic pain do
I have anxiety yeah [ __ ] yeah do I have
stress yeah I guess my sciatic nerve
acts up every once in a while
I have trouble sleeping uh yeah a little
bit Jesus Christ very confronting
[ __ ] ad okay I'm not but I'm not
alone many of us do I have please
discuss in your own words in your own
words all capital letters the issues I
just did you have and how it kept you
from living your best life every day
first of all I'm never doing that my
best life all right I'm lucky enough to
be born in this [ __ ] country look in
the way I'm oh it's always my best life
I lucked out I hit the [ __ ] lottery
see even go out live your best life
alright I was desperate trying anything
that would help but not now Jesus Christ
all right what is fields fields is
premium CBD delivered directly to your
doorstep
what does fields do fields naturally
helps reduce stress anxiety pain and
sleeplessness please talk about the
condition you have and how taking fields
has helped what I haven't taken it yet
I've taken CBD before alright easy to
take place a few drops of feels under
your tongue and feel the difference
within minutes talk of your experience
of how easy it is to use well I mean
I've done that with like echinacea hope
this [ __ ] tastes better real human
support new to CBD fields offers free
CBD hotline and text message support to
help guide your personal experience feel
better naturally I'm a big fan I'll just
say this I'm Nene looking good
anyways I'm a big fan of CBD and all of
this type of [ __ ] and I know it works
because pharmaceutical companies are
freaking the [ __ ] out about it which
means they're just eventually going to
take over take it over right as they
fight it like I feel with like
pharmaceutical companies like all these
drugs that have a million side effects
that's like the fossil fuels of taking
pills and CVD is like hey man like why
don't we switch to solar man you know
they just
like stick cup drops on your tongue man
your livers like cool and you're like
chill around your kids you're not like
harsh in the Mellow Man which that's why
I love Bernie Sanders Bernie Sanders is
the only guy I see running for president
talking about how we have to get we have
to get off these [ __ ] fossil fuels we
got to do it and I'm not saying that
that solar is going to be cleaner as far
as like well what do you do with the old
solar panels that those things won't end
up in the ocean but what we're doing to
the atmosphere with all of that it's
it's time we got to do it I don't
understand why these [ __ ] oil
companies won't just gradually get into
solar they've had 30 [ __ ] years to do
it since Jimmy Carter said were addicted
to oil it would solve so many of our
[ __ ] problems if we stop consuming
all that oil over there then you know so
much of the funding for terrorism is
money gotten from these families that
get the oil money from us funded through
the [ __ ] mosque I mean I don't it's
asinine asinine sorry what I meant to
say is support the troops thoughts and
prayers all right feel better naturally
feels works naturally to help you feel
better there's no high hangover or
addiction see that's great too and a lot
of this other stuff you know you can get
addicted to a membership join the fields
community to get feels delivered to your
door every month you can save money on
every order and you can pause or cancel
anytime I mean it's pretty much the
dream deal here feels will have you
feeling your best every day become a
member today by going to feels calm Fe
als calm / / and you get 50% off your
first order and free shipping
that's Fe ALS dot-com / / to get to
become a member and get 50%
automatically taking off your first
order with free shipping feels calm /
BER alright you know I was just talking
to somebody you know who had an injury
and I was trying to teach them how to
like stretch and stuff like that I'm
telling that's one of the biggest
[ __ ] things eating right and
stretching as you get older
because I was watching this person
trying to do stretches and everything
and it's just like I don't think this
person is trying to touch their toes and
decades and just your body like
literally just like your your range of
motion it just shrinks up you know yeah
bill this isn't groundbreaking all right
whatever I'm just trying to help you
all right hymns why do guys turn to
weird solutions or do nothing when they
can turn to medicine and science for
hymns calm is a one-stop shop for hair
loss skin care sexual wellness for men
look at that you can have a full head of
wavy hair your skin's gonna be clear as
a [ __ ] babies and your decks gonna be
standing right up saluting the flag now
probably shouldn't set as smooth as a
baby and then talk about our an erection
right after that let's do another read
of this that can be sent to them so I
don't [ __ ] lose these people for hims
calm a one step a one-stop shop for hair
loss skin care sexual wellness for men
Jesus Christ that's getting you know you
have a full head of wavy hair skin is
smooth as glass
and your dicks gonna be standing up
attention saluting the flag thanks to
science baldness can be optional I know
that what would you guys do if I took
four hymns if I took hymns and just came
back alright with hair like who's got a
who's got grit who's a guy with like
Justin Alec Baldwin no but it's got to
be somebody like wavy and I always say
the [ __ ] that guy's noodle head guy
I don't know thanks to science every
precaution there's a good there's a good
reference thanks to science baldness can
be optional hims connects with you
connects you with real doctors and
medical grade solutions to treat hair
loss is there anything worse than a
really curly full head of the hair guy
going bald like the straining a guy it's
sort of subtle but the curly head dude
immediately it he just looks like a mad
scientist hims connects you with real
doctors and medical grade solutions to
treat hair loss
well known generic equivalents to
name-brand prescriptions to help you
keep your hair no snake oil pills or gas
station counter supplements prescription
solutions backed by science no waiting
room no awkward in-person doctor visits
save hours by going to for hims fo r
hims calm so easy answer a few quick
questions doctors will review and can
prescribe you that's a weird sentence
answer a few quick questions
doctors will review and can prescribe
you no period no nothing just gonna
leave you dangling there its soda pop
stop worrying about sunblock on that
spot of thinning hair and do something
to help stop hair loss and help promote
hair growth I wish I was sitting right
in front of him and the second he said
its soda pop I just turned around and
stared at him for the rest of the play
my listeners get a month trial get a
trial month of hymns for just $5 right
now while supplies last
see website for full details and safety
information this would cost hundreds if
you went to the doctor or a pharmacy go
to for hims calm / / that's fo r hims
calm / / for hims calm / BER alright
alright can you imagine if I did that
I'm actually I'm just waiting for the
I'm just kind of waiting for the the
one-stop like just like the pill
whenever the I always feel like this ice
to do a bit about this where I felt like
at some point in the future you know you
know sometimes you can take medicine to
like clear up your skin or there's just
an appointment you can put on it like
they'll just be something that you just
put on your head right am i describing
this product that is just read you just
put it on your head and it all comes
back in like five minutes but like with
everything there's always a price to pay
so what it is is it's gonna feel like
your head is on fire literally that
level of pain so what they do is they
strap you down to the gurney
they put like a rag in your mouth and
they're like okay
all right you ready here's our Oh spit
nothing everything or on the fair go
yeah and then they just put it on you
and like for five minutes you decide all
right but when you come out of it you
have a full of full head of [ __ ] hair
near would you go to that come here if
in the future do you have to have that
look on your face if in the future you
got something in your hair
I know I'm joking if it just get to it
you don't want to play oh you're in the
middle doing your beauty [ __ ] all right
get out of here Jesus Christ you know
sometimes sometimes you think your wife
loves you and then other times you're
just like is she just tolerating me I've
just said you up if you can't hear would
you do it five minutes to feel to feel
what it feels like to have your head
literally be on fire you have two hell's
fire on your [ __ ] head and and but
then after five minutes it goes away
five minutes is a long [ __ ] time to
feel like your head is on fire that
would be crazy but then but then you
just have this full head of [ __ ] hair
for the rest of your [ __ ] life but
then here's the thing then there would
be this whole stigma this other stigma
put on bald guys worth then after that
thing existed all right if if you still
were bald than everybody been looking at
you like you're a [ __ ] and all these
guys who never lost their B's [ __ ]
guy over yeah it's just five minutes
come on you [ __ ] [ __ ] you rightly
know they'd say more than that but you
know I'd love to say those words anymore
but that's what they would say and they
would pressure you into living your best
life all right let's do another read
here all right
stamps.com mama mama mama
alright stamps.com everybody you know
not everyone not really no one really
has time to go to the post office your
busy mall it all depends on how you
prioritize who's got time for all that
traffic parking lugging all your mail
and packages yeah exactly and it's this
sort of a rule with every post office
that you know they serve like [ __ ]
900,000 people and there's about
fourteen park 19:14 there's like [ __ ]
three parking spots and one of them's
for one of the jeeps it's a real hassle
man
that's why you need stamps calm one of
the most popular time-saving tools for
small businesses stamps calm eliminates
trips to the post office and saves you
money with discounts that you can't even
get at the post office stamps comp
brings all the amazing services of the
u.s. post office right to your computer
whether you're a small office sending
invoices and online seller shipping out
products or even a warehouse sending
thousands of packages a day
stamps.com can handle it with ease
simply use your computer to print out
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send right now my slash our
listeners get a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale without any
long-term commitment just go to stamp
stop com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in birbee URR that
stamps.com enter / write well where the
hell are we in this podcast here where
are we at thirty-six minutes then well
it looks like it looks like it's time
for [ __ ] some of the reads here
alright assault and battery alright bill
you are right that every state is
different New York does not have battery
assault is the physical action when you
hurt someone menacing is when a you make
a person fear you will assault them is
that just in New York come on guys you
know I'm dumb I can't figure this out
every state is different so in New York
assault is the physical action when you
hurt someone menacing is when okay okay
so you're saying that in New York and
then other places
menacing well that's a lot clearer I
think assault and menacing as opposed to
assault and battery cuz then you think
he was beating the [ __ ] out of me and
then you know afterwards he took the
batteries out of his Walkman and threw
him at me
oh really his that all you got [ __ ] you
says Sunday
all right Frosty's and a [ __ ]
follow-up from a lady dear Billy back in
my day yeah I would have thought I got
more [ __ ] about the M&M store the way
Mia gave me [ __ ] by the way I bought
M&Ms at the plane I am a lady and wanted
to help the young fellas out there who
want their girls or partners or whatever
to go to the gym Oh Nia listen to this
one
this guy he was in that awful situation
where you know he he was staying in
shape and his girlfriend who he loved
was getting a little bigger anyone to
try to encourage her to go to the gym
and she kept saying that she wanted to
go to the gym but every time he would
say all right let's go to the gym she'd
either do the little sad puppy dog thing
she did that at first and that would
work so then when that wasn't working
she's now started to blow him like when
Karen asked Ray Liotta for [ __ ] money
you know and Goodfellas so you want to
get in on this all right so I was just
like how the [ __ ] you know it's very
hard you know to communicate that
sometimes you just think the only way to
say it is to say it hey sweetheart I
love you but you're getting real fat all
right
I don't want to [ __ ] a fatty so why
don't you get to the gym and I don't get
on the elliptical tub you can't say that
all right I'm a lady and working
ultimately bill is right no one can make
her do it and she won't do it until
she's ready but you can try leading by
example see this is why women are
smarter than guys is because they can
get people to do things without saying I
need you to do this they can get in your
head man and they
run around alright you want to ease your
girl into the habit of moving her body
and the rest will and the rest will fall
okay you want to get your girl into the
habit of moving her body and the rest
will follow
suggest going for a walk together daily
maybe plan your route to hit a couple of
hills or a short hike with some incline
this is [ __ ] brilliant he's in there
wail okay go for a walk it's a nice time
up and then you literally feel it here's
a little more challenging Hill it's like
when they would slowly turn the [ __ ]
heat up on the rat and the rent wouldn't
get out of the pot suggest going for a
walk daily okay there's usually a time
of night after dinner mid net Netflix
that you or your girl wants a sweet
treat before that happens go on a walk
after a couple of weeks increase that to
a jog and no not a walk to [ __ ]
Wendy's Jesus Christ we just said to go
get something sweet I mean just oh I'm
stupid there's usually time a night
before that happens go on a walk oh I
see I see I see all right I mean just
the fact that she eats Wendy's Frosty's
you really drink them or sort of gulp
them down and frozen clumps speaking
from experience
it's grounds for termination in my book
but I digress come on sit down come here
come here come here
okay all right so go on okay so here we
go
Nia said what who doesn't like Frosty's
I don't don't eat that [ __ ] that's
delicious
oh boy that's good clean fun well boy oh
boy alright anyways but I digress don't
eat that [ __ ] buy yourselves some real
[ __ ] ice cream with few ingredients
if you have if you have to have it I
mean that makes sense or here's a
[ __ ] no-brainer when she wants a
frosty instead of her giving you a blowy
why did it become a blowy
why don't you just suggest it's more
digestible to say blow it's funny
instead of her giving you a blowy why
don't you suggest no frosty and you'll
go down on her yeah but why do you wait
a minute me I'm gonna stop [ __ ]
smoking cigars and drinking booze if you
blow me I mean where's the sacrifice on
her [ __ ] part that is such a you know
what you were [ __ ] cool until there I
don't know about that one anyways what a
concept her reward for not eating like a
child is an orgasm well yeah
another gross one do G [ __ ] a door
out he performed the leash no there are
a group of dancing oh I thought fellatio
was just any oral sex no fellatio is
sucking a dick correct and what is it
cunnilingus cunnilingus cunnilingus
cunnilingus cu nn I never took a health
class I don't think they teach you about
[ __ ] alingas and health class they don't
they don't go that's a vagina and this
is the guy's tongue and he goes down
there and he goes you guys know that
Christmas Carol oh la la they didn't do
that no no no my generation we like
people who learn an instrument by ear
it's all just trying to figure it out
alright well there are group dance
classes in a studio or online aerobics
classes spin classes yoga Pilates all of
these things have been designed to take
your hard-earned money so give it to him
go to yoga together go to Zumba together
and you'll get what about his workout he
wants to be all buff he wants to throw
the [ __ ] weights around on like an
off day where it's just like I was just
gonna do 30 minutes of cardio or
something like that do one I see what
she's saying that the whole idea is like
you're doing it together so it's time
it's quality time together it's like fun
you know it's not such a like what I
want to know is at some point can he
then just set her free
and she can work out the way she wants
to work out and he can go back to his
workout was like
NUI with me the thing is though she
likes she if she doesn't want to like
exercise to go to the gym she's not
gonna go and she's gonna be smart enough
to know that it's like wait a minute are
you trying to force me to exercise and
that could be seen as being like kind of
manipulative and not cool so I mean like
you know let's slow let's go for a walk
together I feel like that's very like
non confrontational and non like it's
just you know let's just go for a walk
guys are too smart you'll figure that I
oh now we're gonna go up this hill Oh
wouldn't it be fun to it's like no I
thought we were just gonna go on a nice
walk together now you got me [ __ ]
huffing and puffing and although this of
you didn't tell me I needed to put my
[ __ ] leggings on you know so this
this the Lamar ring this email the more
it's like annoying me because then she
goes she goes anyways you'll get to
experience a level of shame yourself by
being a man in that environment like
these places [ __ ] Jazzercise bro time
to get humble why does he have to do why
does he have to like she's acting like
he didn't go to the gym it's not like
anybody's job to get their partner to
where you can encourage them and be like
I want you to be healthy I know you're
worried you know about gaining weight or
you don't want to gain weight I just
want to encourage you I don't want to
force you but like let's go for like
walks together this is starting to sound
like his girlfriend wrote this now it's
getting a little anger because listen
this stop acting like going to the gym
is the only way to get in shape the gym
isn't for everyone no because that's the
way this is reading to me and when
you're out of shape the gym can be
pretty intimidating because not everyone
is comfortable with the level of shame
it takes to go in there sign up admit
you're a lazy [ __ ] and get on the
treadmill she's going off the rails here
there are so many other ways to exercise
and you got to help her find what works
for her why is this his [ __ ] job
but I don't know just like this [ __ ]
tone is ridiculous I don't I don't yeah
I don't get any any of that [ __ ] like
there's nothing like if he was not for
us anybody to work out and be healthy
and if he was the guy not going to the
gym like it wouldn't be like you need to
start going to the gym and lifting
weights you don't humble yourself this
is like this is this [ __ ] [ __ ] it's a
one-way street all right sorry all right
thank you lovely near we are creatures
of habit when she gets into the habit of
moving she want to do it more and then
she'll dump you when she looks hot as
[ __ ] so be careful what you wish for
yeah she went she got all [ __ ] did
you notice how she tried to act like she
was cool and in the end she wasn't come
here so is that why you guys stay with
us so you can eat a burger but if you if
you stop eating the [ __ ] burger then
you're gonna dump us and where you're
gonna go what do you mean cuz you said
that you were thinking that to let go
what if she gets all hot and then breaks
up with them like I can do better
yeah turned around she got an amazing
shape and then she went off and you know
I think it's funny that working out I've
been really just me meditating and
taking care of myself and I realized
you're a piece of [ __ ] by isn't it more
I realized that guys who are doing
better than you are now looking at me
and I would like to swing to the next
monkey bar of a better lifestyle maybe
maybe could be could be you have to dip
out my interview skills are [ __ ] next
level yeah Jesus Christ I mean you're
right there I mean do you see this dish
right here this all right here is why I
suggest any guy don't be afraid if your
wife ever says hey we know we need to go
to couples counseling because for the
first time in their lives somebody
outside the relationship is going to
tell them at some point that they're
[ __ ] wrong
but then you're gonna pay for it in the
car ride home so it doesn't it doesn't
work it's just this guy loves the woman
he's trying to help her out and in the
end she's basically telling the guy that
he needs to Humble himself she you know
all her issues with going to the gym is
she flips out and then in the end she
goes hey you know rather than hey you
know what you're a really good guy you
care for your girl you know this is a
great thing that you care so much that
you're doing this it's like yeah well I
should get hot and [ __ ] dump you
alrighty
yeah alrighty then there you go there's
that there's that well what I would say
is if that actually happens that she
never really loved you to begin with and
so then if you didn't take her to the
gym then you'd be married to a fat
miserable [ __ ] who doesn't really love
you and is only there because they're
too [ __ ] fat to roll out of your life
all right Scott Peterson documentary you
know Jesus
oh yeah 70 bill your mustachioed [ __ ]
I'm curious of your take on the Scott
Peterson case in the mid-2000s the Scott
Peterson oh he was the one who killed
that his pregnant wife rather than just
breaking up with her you know it's
[ __ ] is he would have been done with
child support right about now instead he
killed two people and I was sitting in
jail [ __ ] dope I was too young at the
time to follow the news that closely
though admittedly I don't watch it now
either I saw this ane documentary on
hulu called the murder of Laci Peterson
yeah it goes in about how media coverage
forced the police to rush the case and
target only Scott and how emotional
outrage from the public contributed to
the decision of the death penalty well I
mean don't don't [ __ ] kill your
pregnant wife I mean yeah that's gonna
be a little sensational thing you think
granted the makers could be biased and
framed the case their own way but I
thought it was very well made
well you got to watch out with those
things because those things have their
mind made up I can over that [ __ ]
thing that was on Netflix the making of
a murderer I thought what's this Doug
Stanhope had the best take on that he's
like he threw a live cat into a fire and
watched it burn to death [ __ ] this guy
and it's like you know they can make you
feel whatever you want to feel I had a
buddy of mine watch that stupid Cortney
whatever the [ __ ] name is the chick
from hole why am I thinking Cox Courtney
Love Kurt Cobain story and like he
watched that thing by the end of it he
was convinced that a junkie from three
states away pulled off a murder that
[ __ ] with today's technology they
couldn't figure out that she [ __ ] did
it alright anyways granted the makers
could be by sarivola though through the
documentary and my minimal Wikipedia
research follow-up I'm convinced that
the trial was unfair
Scott shouldn't be on death row and
should win his appeal there was no
physical evidence multiplet people saw
Lacey the day she was supposedly already
dead a robbery occurred directly across
the street the day she went missing and
multiple pregnant women six or seven I
think had gone missing in the area
within a year or so of Lacey's
disappearance granted Scott's a sleazy
cheating piece of [ __ ] but so are a lot
of douchebags anyway twelve this is I
was curing curious if you've seen the
documentary or even just what you
remember about the case figured this
might peak you're in informed conspiracy
believing ass thanks and go [ __ ]
yourself oh so you just throwing this
across the table to watch me go nuts
about it I don't know anything about
that case all I can say is I hope he's
[ __ ] guilty because he's done a lot
of time no I don't know anything about
that but I've always wondered I never
understood why guys kill their wives you
know is bad is child support and alimony
as bad as you think it's going to be is
that going to be worse
then killing the mother your child and
going to jail for the rest of your
[ __ ] life and God knows what happens
in the afterlife if there is a bad place
you go to you just signed up for that
because you didn't want to do 18 years
of [ __ ] alimony and child support
good lord
[ __ ] is wrong with people why I don't
believe water is a human right oh good
God Almighty you know sometimes people
just try to [ __ ] this this is like
one of these [ __ ] things where I just
feel like just somebody's just trying to
piss me off
Oh maybe the person is being a joke okay
I've heard you on multiple thing they're
being sarcastic I've heard on multiple
occasions express your belief that water
is a human right in 2010 the United
Nations determined that because people
have the right to life and since water
is essential to life water is a human
right well thank God my issue with this
is that the line of thinking can be
taking further example food is necessary
therefore is also human right the same
thing with housing toiletries and many
other things this feels to me like a
fast-track to socialism / communism and
we all know how that goes wink I hope I
helped you think no because here's the
thing I can live outside okay I can live
you can live outside all most people do
it for years decades all right they're
only going to you're only gonna last
about like three four days without
[ __ ] water everything you you can go
six weeks without food up to six weeks I
should say what else did you say housing
you can live outside toiletries who says
you need [ __ ] toiletries no water is
a [ __ ] human right because if you
don't have it in three days you [ __ ]
dead all right everything else gives you
time to get there all right I mean I and
I also agree with food and I also agree
with shelter okay and all these people
out there we don't think that you should
[ __ ] try to help out your fellow man
it's [ __ ] ridiculous
and that we should all just keep our
[ __ ] mouth shut while five to ten
corporations keep us in a never-ending
[ __ ] war that has no exit strategy
that has bankrupted this [ __ ] country
that's fine that's fine for those [ __ ]
guys to do that and overcharge us and
leave no future for our [ __ ] children
children's children and Weddell of that
[ __ ] okay
but god forbid you help some [ __ ] guy
you know who played football hurt his
[ __ ] knee was given fentanyl and is
now doing heroin in his homeless God for
[ __ ] bid you help that guy out makes
no [ __ ] sense to me but what am I you
know I'm a big [ __ ] Hollywood phony
why listen to me Oh furs he's calling
Birds he's calling call I should have
picked up and giving a [ __ ] about the
Yankees let's get you shaky in the Bronx
but I don't do that I don't do that all
right
advice for a lady amen love your stuff
what a [ __ ] am I here okay that's
warning advice for a lady hey man love
your stuff longtime fan first-time
emailer I am in need of some advice I
love my job as a landscaper and God
nough but my boss sometimes says [ __ ]
that is really inappropriate
he'll occasionally comment on my nice
ass or how he likes working with the hot
girl who knows how to work one day a
plant delivery guy showed up and when my
boss introduced me he started saying
really nice stuff like she really gets
[ __ ] done and she works harder than most
guys I've been I've had working for me
but then finished by saying but the best
part about working with her is looking
at her I am so embarrassed but all I
could manage was to roll my eyes and
shrug a he shouldn't be doing this I
don't think he's actually malicious he's
actually most was creepies and overly
he's overall pretty decent boss I think
he's just over a certain age and a
certain type of guy that is oblivious to
how lame that is yeah that's a fair
assessment I don't really want to have a
super serious conversation with them
about how this makes me feel
because that one makes things more
awkward I think that's what you say to
him they said can I talk to you for a
second I don't want to have a super
serious conversation but like I I don't
I don't want to hear you talking about
my ass or any more body parts or
anything like that
okay just talk to him about me like a
worker okay I don't I don't want to hear
those comments anymore
and there's no way he's not informed
enough to know that he's getting himself
into dangerous territory if he continues
I would think anyways he says when he
says stuff like that I usually just clam
up and try to get away from him but I
was hoping you could help me with some
kind of snarky retort well is he older
I'd like to be able to respond in a way
that is light-hearted but not I am NOT a
light-hearted person but also points out
that he's being a creep send me a
picture of them I'll give you all the
ammo you need unfortunately I haven't
been able to because I get too flustered
in the moment I would love to hear any
input Nia might have as well thanks and
go [ __ ] yourself garden girl I I don't
know what it is it's just do me a favor
once you go dye your pubes just make fun
of his [ __ ] but then you don't want him
to get hostile or whatever I would just
talk to him just so that I think the
thing is you you have like
confrontational issues here that you got
to get past now everybody in the [ __ ]
the the [ __ ] social media right now
will be like I'm blaming the victim I'm
not I'm giving you the tools you need
cuz you're gonna need to confront this
[ __ ] guy so just learn that it'll
just write down on a piece of paper what
you want to say rehearse it memorize it
and then just say it to him and then
what happens is it's it's not like you
don't know what you want to say it's not
like you don't know how you feel you
have so much anxiety about confronting
this [ __ ] person that you're going to
get outside of yourself that's how you
bomb is a comedian the beginning is
you're gonna the cars looking at me I
forgot my jokes it's the same thing so
one thing in life you have to get good
at is confrontation because if you don't
people are going to take advantage of
you and it's going to build up
resentment
you and you're gonna end up being a
really [ __ ] angry person alright take
it from me
alright my anger is all for my [ __ ]
childhood cuz I didn't know how to
confront people and it just kept getting
stacked onto it and I'm trying to
whittle away at it and every time I
knock off a couple of [ __ ] pounds
some content of theater goes it's soda
pop and it comes right back so that's
what I would do I would just be like
yeah I I don't think you're a bad guy
but that really makes me feel
uncomfortable and I wish you would stop
doing that not even I wish I want I want
I need you I need you to stop doing that
alright and hopefully it's not one of
those old-school guys you do [ __ ]
[ __ ]
whatever who gives a [ __ ] alright and
what if that fails I don't know just
tell him you're either you that you're a
size Queen and you can tell by the way
he carries himself he's not up for the
job I don't don't say that I don't know
what I don't know have fun with it have
fun with the confrontation alright high
school [ __ ] I hope that helped you out
but [ __ ] him if it's gonna be awkward
he's the one making it he's making he's
the one making it weird alright so push
through it say what you have to say and
start [ __ ] start getting good at it
practice it practice confronting people
on it my mother's calling hang on a
second Jesus Christ message her oh hang
on a second I get I gotta take this
hang on you know at some point I'm gonna
get I got to get a [ __ ] studio
I think the interruptions the
interruptions you know trying to just
sit in the middle of your house doing a
podcast what the [ __ ] is wrong with me
all right last thing dilemma Dara bill
or will
what's worse bulla Willem your Bible
bill Bowl having no fingers are havin no
dick you were born with both and one of
them has to get cut off well how old am
i you know for me I need my fingers to
[ __ ] open up my Geritol not using my
dick anymore I don't know if I've never
had a family I want a dick and he goes I
know this is a stupid one it really
makes you think either never be able to
use your fingers again or never be able
to have sex
Beechum eat or pee standing up again
what do you think bill man that that's
it that's the tough one it's not the
[ __ ] sex of jerking off thing once
you get to my [ __ ] age it's the what
the [ __ ] do I have when I got to relieve
myself
I got it I have the solution this isn't
actually an easy one I would have no
dick therefore I would still have my
fingers so I could easily blow my brains
out there you go there's your solution
of that one all right I guess you know
unless you have a crooked dick then he
could take the fingers off and I don't
know what anyways that's that's the
podcast god bless you congratulations a
Red Sox if one three or 400 or swept the
Yankees who knows but you know if we
don't sweep them then they still have a
nine-game lead they still have seven
there's a long [ __ ] way to go but
whatever we'll see hopefully it'll be a
race but uh I would definitely be
concerned with the pitching if I was a
Yankee fan but I would
concern to the level that the New York
sports meetings only need to be done
right now it's like you should have been
saying that all [ __ ] year it's been a
problem all [ __ ] year maybe they have
been I don't know I haven't been looking
whatever all right enjoy your next
couple of days I'll check in on you on
Thursday
thanks - go [ __ ] yourselves and I'll
talk to you soon